life must be miserable for everyone in a
zombie apocalypse but teenagers would
have it particularly tough just imagine
how depressing it would be you want to
have fun experience all the goofy joy
out there but the adults are just
talking about survival fists and
survival that left behind examines this
bleak existence we see the world through
the eyes of Ellie and better understand
what it would be like to live in a place
where undead monsters are the norm left
behind is a prequel to The Last of Us
we're introduced to Ellie years before
she meets Joel and we see how she grew
from naive kid to hardened survivor her
companion is Riley she's slightly older
than Ellie and though they had a
falling-out a month earlier they put
past grievances behind them who wants to
hold a grudge when there's an exciting
world to explore so you two set out to
an abandoned mall because that's where
every teenager hangs out there's an easy
back and forth between these two friends
it's very different from the dialogue in
The Last of Us sullen angry Joel
smothered Ellie's enthusiasm
whereas Riley shares in it their sheer
delight in their giddy exchanges so much
so that I was laughing right along with
them it's so pure and genuine that I
didn't want their silly conversations to
end so of course it has to end
happiness isn't allowed to thrive in
zombie stories after all interspersed
between the scenes with Riley and Ellie
having fun are dangerous encounters
years in the future here Ellie is
already met Joel though she's at a point
where she must fend for herself the mood
is very different than it is in the
other moments there's no time for jokes
there's no time for levity it's bleak
and sad and all too real the jarring
mood swings between these two sections
greatly affected me I was so used to
playful atmosphere and having to face
the truth it was too much to bear I just
wanted to spend time goofing off with
Riley and Ellie that's the beauty of
left behind them it isn't hide from
reality Ellie has to grow up at some
point and though it hurt to see or
hardened it's for the best
she won't be able to survive otherwise
when you're with Riley there's not much
in the way of traditional action instead
exploration is the focus whether you're
looking around in a Halloween store or
snap
photos at a booth every moment is meant
to give new insight into these
characters such deliberate pacing really
welcomed me into this difficult world
everything shifts when you're alone with
Elie here there are real threats
infected and mercenaries are trying to
kill you
so character building is established
through combat encounters rather than
conversation le is fierce and determined
but she's not stupid avoiding a fight is
obviously much smarter than trying to be
a hero and ending a bitten and so
sneaking is the wisest option I made
friends with shadows use bottles as a
distraction it did my best to keep her
out of harm's way unfortunately the last
fight forces you to kill enemies with no
infected nearby our sure I'd be able to
enter locked door but the game wouldn't
allow it I had to kill every last
monster it felt like it was pushing me
to do something opposed to Ellie's will
and that made me feel dirty
still the combat is tense and rewarding
the brutality of the Last of Us is
presented here though there is a wrinkle
thrown it mercs an infected now mix you
can get the two sides to attack one
another seeing the people hunting me
torn to shreds with satisfying more than
I'd like to admit so this was a great
addition left behind is a huge success
not only does it borrow some of the best
elements of the Last of Us
but it also forges its own path one
that's very powerful the mood is so
different without Joel around that I was
absorbed in ways that the main game
seemed to block me out left behind is an
excellent addition to this series that
gives further insight to this terrible
world and its most fascinating character
you